Karin Jean-Pierre spokesman for the
president will not say whether or not
the White House would be willing to try
to shut Twitter down as the White House
has suggested in recent days
when you say that you're going to be
monitoring some of the speech on there
if you see something that you don't like
would you try to shut Twitter down so
look you know when you when you talk
about monitoring you know it is uh I I
hate to break it to you Peter just like
everybody else we very much monitor the
news we pay close attention to
everything that you all are reporting
and and Twitter's in the news a lot and
so that's what we're paying attention to
we're paying attention to what is in the
news and what is being reported on uh on
the misinformation that's out there
let's not forget there's groups like
NAACP the Anti-Defamation League and the
public health leaders have been very
vocal about their concerns as well so
yes we are reading what you all are are
writing and and looking at what you all
are reporting about the misinformation
that is out there but you know I would
hope that all Americans including social
media companies civil rights
organizations I just laid out including
Fox as well will agree that that we need
to uh you know we need to uh to uh you
know call out hate speech and
misinformation that's a whole lot of
words to say the White House might try
to shut down Twitter
for allowing conservatives to speak on
there that's a whole lot of words to say
it but that's what she's saying it's a
simple question
you guys have talked about how you're
monitoring Twitter because now Twitter
is is allowing conservatives to speak
more freely are you willing to shut it
down
well you know I mean look we gotta look
we gotta look at things and maybe you
know look that's a nice Twitter you got
there sure would be a shame if something
happened to it
so I know the reason I mention this I'm
not surprised at all that the Democrats
are willing to wield the government to
shut down conservatives from having a
voice in the Public Square
but I don't want to hear peep from
Democrats on the authoritarian overreach
of Ron DeSantis going after Disney the
White House is threatening to shut down
Twitter if it allows conservatives to
have a voice in the Public Square I
don't want to hear anything about
wielding the government against the
private corporations give me a break the
Democrats have been doing that since
forever and they continue to do it today
in a much more aggressive way than the
conservatives do I don't want to hear it
well no but it's to stop hate speech oh
yeah hate speech by which the Democrats
mean uh speech that they don't like by
which the Democrats mean any speech from
any conservative ever Ron DeSantis says
he's going to keep going there's been a
threat in recent days that Apple might
kick Twitter out of the app store
because Elon Musk is allowing
conservatives to speak on Twitter again
and this is simply unacceptable so Apple
says okay maybe we're going to get rid
of of Twitter if if Apple and Android
did that Twitter would basically just
disappear it would not exist because
those two companies own the smartphone
market
Rhonda Santa says if Apple kicks Twitter
out of the App Store
we should take Anti-Trust action and
bust them up
we did Big Tech censorship Bill two
years ago it's gotten caught up in the
courts I think the U.S Supreme Court's
going to accept that case for this term
Texas has a similar case there's a
conflict in the circuits and so whatever
the states can do to protect people's
rights to engage in free expression and
you know what some of these companies do
they get a lot of benefits from the
government as you said Pat and things
like that the social media companies get
liability protection and yet they turn
around and they use that protection to
marginalize voices they disagree with so
I think from the Congressional
perspective though they need to look at
antitrust with these massive companies
because they are exercising massive
amounts of power over our society
so the most interesting political battle
here is not the right versus the left
you know the right wing Ron DeSantis
versus the left-wing Apple the most
interesting battle the most
controversial aspect of this is the
right versus the right the most
interesting battle here is the
libertarian point of view versus the
conservative point of view the
libertarian point of view which is well
you don't like what Apple's doing build
your own Apple build your own Twitter
versus the conservative point of view
now we're going to bring you guys into
line you you woke corporations are
selling out our political order you are
doing things that are deeply wrong and
unjust and we're going to wield
political power to bring you back into
line and Ron DeSantis is siding with the
conservatives it's it's the battle
between
politics is Downstream of culture
and
the law is a teacher okay because
politics is Downstream of culture is is
true in as much as it's true yeah it's
true that the movies affect the
political order in fact that's why we're
all so concerned about what Disney is
doing
but the way that that phrase has been
used has basically been as a way to let
Republican politicians off the hook to
say that you know Politics the
government is not how we should solve
any of our problems we should only make
movies we should only engage in the
cultural battles and because it would be
so unjust to wield the government versus
the traditional view which is of course
course we should wield the government
why why else do we run for elections of
course the government can fix some
problems
of course the law is a teacher
and we we should know that because
conservatives and Libertarians prattle
on all the time about how the government
creates certain incentives and that can
lead to bad outcomes we talk about how
in the 1960s the government created all
these perverse incentives with the rise
of the welfare state and all sorts of
terrible laws and that that led to bad
outcomes because those incentives
changed people's behavior well if the
government can create incentives that
make people's behavior worse the
government also can create incentives
that make people's behavior better of
course that's always been true of course
the law is a teacher and so what Rhonda
santis is saying is yeah we're gonna
okay you Movie Makers you go making
movies and you people in in the culture
or Private Industry obviously you do you
do what you you do the best that you can
you fix the culture from your angle but
I'm going to wield the government okay
and 10 years ago I bet a lot of
conservatives and Republicans would not
have spoken like this or would not have
wanted to hear that kind of message but
this is a different time and I think
Rhonda dentist knows what time it is
[Music]
[Music]